[Music]
hey what's up everybody does the light
look weird to you or I didn't touch
anything looks normal to me okay this is
the I just I just wondered maybe I'm
just imagining that normal I don't
really know yeah whatever but uh Hey
everybody it's Friday night we're going
out tonight we're going out tonight but
we're doing well I mean we told you guys
that before so we're doing like a little
pregame show for a couple hours y before
we head out to mannequins this evening
we haven't been there for a few months I
feel like as hot as Jen's looking I'm
going to have to be on my tippy toes man
I'm GNA be fierce as a [__]
you're not allowed to go to the bathroom
cuz they're going to try to molest
this the way it looks now yeah we don't
know we haven't been in a couple months
I've I've heard it's better like because
they charge they charge a cover now yeah
and uh you know they're more security
supposed to be keep cover keeps the Riff
Raff Out Security is make you know
they're
[__] using metal detectors to make
sure nobody's carrying guns in there
which that's good I carry my guns
[__] with me wherever I go you know
you can't get rid of them can't get rid
of these guns and then like
uh but the the cover charge and security
keeps most of them out yeah they had to
kind of go that way yeah I'm not going
to have to fight probably as much as I
used to no you won't yeah but uh we're
going to have to show this [__]
outfit off J look at this [__] right
here hold on this [__] look at this
[__] look at his
outfit I got my big ass boots on that
you got me for Christmas and this dress
you just got me too yeah look at that
shit's it's like a damn deck of an
aircraft
carrier look at go stand up je oh jeez
here we go this is a [__] great
dominatrix outfit over there I got to go
over here yeah okay yeah my hair keeps
going in my boat crack yeah you know
what I mean yeah turn around let's see
the back of that boat the I think we
boots before yeah cuz I think I wore
them only went in momento buckles going
down the back of the boots yeah they're
cool yeah they're super comfy turn
around there you go
yep there she goes you're hilarious Miss
dominatrix yeah you got to put that back
I'm not I'm put back you're the one that
wants to take it off I'm just we give
everyone wearing my motion sickness yeah
kind of wearing
my okay Zach says I like the stoner rug
yeah
yeah don't tell uh don't tell uh Mecca
that that's a damn Persian that's a
prayer
rug that's a prayer rug well it can be
both
[Laughter]
yeah uh Zan says amazing boots yeah I
love these Tom got me these for
Christmas or actually your mom got me
these for Christmas but you told her to
get I told her what get her yeah so yeah
they're above the knee boot yeah they go
above the KNE which is yeah I never um
had any of those before yeah it go look
the first one quarter of the thigh when
I was younger I always wanted boots like
that but my calves and thighs were
always too
fat so like I couldn't wear them you
know what I mean but you know yeah now
once my legs got skinnier I was able to
like wear the training
helps yeah I mean I'm talking about when
I was like young like a teenager in my
20s okay go ahead and uh yeah so Zan is
here Zan sent us some
movies look it we got the Departed and
Inception Inception yes I'm very excited
these are going to be real good you're
going to love these he's also said he's
sending me a Criterion Edition we're to
Russian flick that's what's the name of
that Russ is it come and see come and
see he says I've been wanting to see
that for a long time even though I've
heard it's like super Soul crushing but
I'm kind of into that and I was like
those Criterion additions are expensive
but that's the only format he can get it
in I said dude you don't have to do that
he goes no man [__] I know I don't
have to but [__] I want to give it to
you anything Criterion addition you're
[__] running 80
bucks sometimes they do a nice job on it
and yeah and that is like the complete
definitive [__] edition of that movie
the highest quality with [__] ton of
extras books uh [__] probably like hours
and hours of [__] edit of like uh a
video usually like from the making of
the production and interviews with
directors that kind of stuff so it's
just like the definitive version of the
movie so we are definitely going to be
reviewing at least one of those on
Monday we just we haven't decided we'll
see which move line to go yeah yeah yeah
and then we'll do the other one like the
the Monday following yeah but we can
either watch them tomorrow night or
Sunday night we'll see how that goes
because like I said tomorrow we got to
go to Okala yeah because I got to go to
my uh stepdad's funeral so there's that
so we got to get up kind of early not
early early but kind of early we can't
sleep in we can't sleep in right yeah
which so it's probably dumb that we're
going out tonight but oh well we can do
it yeah we can do it we can always leave
early yeah yeah we don't have to stay
all night yeah right although you know
how that usually goes we're like ah we
don't have to be there that long and
then it's like 3: in the morning we're
like a [__] I I'll [__] party all
night I'll wake up at 9 o00 anyway I
don't I don't it doesn't really matter I
usually wake up as soon as the sun comes
in the window now if you close the
blinds then I'll just sleep all day
because I'll think it's still night time
but usually got the blinds open you wake
I wake up yeah but if the blinds are
open then I'll wake right up as soon as
the sun comes up okay so uh who we got
here
everybody everybody Sebastian iris is in
Beth
Zack um everybody's in here everybody's
here Jeffy yard in Murder Hornet said my
parents live kind of close to Okala yeah
oh how close Okala is still almost
almost what an hour hour away though
it's yeah we looked up where the
cemetery was it's an hour and 11 minutes
from from here so and it's not that far
from my mom's house but I've never been
there so we'll see how it goes but yeah
we just got to get up early and drive
over there tomorrow I just you know I
didn't want to drive by myself I don't
you know I don't really want to
have to subject you to funeral after you
know your dad just died and everything
damn funerals everybody died I know holy
crap and I just went to like I said I
just went to my grandma's funeral like a
month ago or something like that or
whenever it was I don't remember six
weeks ago so you know but what are you
going to do you get older that's the
kind of [__] that happens yeah just got
to just got to deal with it uh Jeffy art
says by the way you guys look great
thank you very much uh also says I just
put my two weeks into my security job
pursuing other another degree I'll need
my weekends back that's really cool so
good luck with that uh Zan says um yeah
come and see it says Jenny will love it
oh I'm sure I will like I said I've read
a lot about it and I'm just like man I
really need to see that but I just
haven't got around to it yet all right I
haven't got around to it Zack says uh I
could use an opinion guys I have a
friend
who's is it caress or caros I mean it
says caress but I you know uh and
jobless at the moment and lives in a
dead end town I want to help him out but
I don't know how wish I could help him
move somewhere more
urban I mean that may not be the answer
to short of like giving people money
there's really not much you can do I
guess is he one of your gay friends I
mean you can get any ass out of this oh
oh now don't be that way
Tom is that the only reason you help
people everybody you've helped over
everybody you've helped over the
years uh no no I guess that's not the
only reason no that's not the only when
it comes to sh money when it comes to
show drill down on this shelling out
money and moving people around that was
something I did for Like Girls when I
was [__] younger all right before I
was married uh yeah like oh yeah but you
know
um so you know I don't know what he's
thinking
there you don't help people try import
you trying to import a boyfriend or
something you don't just help people out
of the goodness of your heart yeah okay
yeah you know if I
can I yeah I guess you do but you know
I'm kind of selfish yeah the way you
said that you were just kind of like nah
there's got to be something authenticity
in being a selfish you know what I'm
talking about that's that's well for you
not everybody's like that like I don't I
don't consider myself a particularly
selfish person everybody is to some
degree but cuz that's just kind of you
know but I I don't know I I don't think
I am but yeah I I don't know um let's
see Zan said come andc see is amazing it
took me two years to watch it finally
but it's good yeah that's what I've
heard I've heard it's like one of the
best movies if there's a criterian
addition of it that means it's good
movie yeah they they don't really make I
can't really think of any Criterion
movie that I mean I'm sure some someone
will remind me of something but I don't
they're at least important yeah even if
he yeah and and I'm just saying that
it's like not because saying something
is a bad movie yeah that's kind of you
you can say you don't care for a movie
like even if it's a classic that doesn't
make it a bad movie that just means you
personally don't Vibe with it and that's
cool you know what I mean if Criterion
has a has a version of it's because it's
an important movie yeah exactly yeah
ganthers Hammer is here in the house
what's up
Hammer that's Hammer Time It's Hammer
Time yeah yes Tammy says I haven't slept
since past 7:30 since we got our dogs
yeah that's another thing um maybe if we
leave the treat plate empty yeah then
Pooky will jump up on our heads and be
like what the
[__] she'll she'll wake us up Pooky
drives me crazy she loves her daddy all
she does is climb up on my chest and
she'll go up there like [__] three
minutes and go away she she'll do when
I'm awake too just all day long daddy
daddy daddy daddy daddy daddy and then
she tries to get underneath my what my
tries to put her head underneath my hand
okay all right right I'll Pat you and
then she'll get up stand and turn around
on this on my chest try to walk down my
stomach yeah then jump off you know what
I mean when when she jumps off she it's
like you're being kicked you know yeah
cuz she's not she's not a light cat no
she's very she's very small yeah small
and fat she's a little Chub she's a
little Chub she yeah and uh then she
comes back I don't know how much she
weighs 15 minutes later and does it
again over and over stepping on your
nuts and stuff yeah yeah she didn't step
on my nuts anymore yeah she used to she
used to she used to jump on them and I'm
sure she did that on purpose she knew
what she in bed she boom and then jump
down and then hit my nuts and jump off
of them she's not dumb yeah she knew
exactly she thought it was funny yeah
she thought it was funny she hasn't done
that in a long time though it's funny
yeah um he's got Pooky following him
around uh or like just sitting on him
all the time and meanwhile yeah Bambi
our other little kitty is my little
Shadow yeah everywhere I go she follows
me around walking in front of me
flopping walking in front of me flopping
she like pet my belly please grandfather
says I had six people in my circle die
within a two-month period last year when
it rains it pours yeah it's just kind of
like man the last few months has been
crazy you know grur said that he had six
people in a circle die within a
two-month period yeah yeah they di
they're all Dy well like I said once you
get to that point I mean you know we're
in our 50s now so yeah you got to kind
of expect it it's still a bummer but
yeah my dad was 77 yeah he was lucky to
live that long with all the you know he
was a diabetic real bad diabetic and
smoked like a pack and a half a day two
packs for a while just smoked a [__]
[__] ton and didn't really eat all that
well you know he was L he was lucky to
live
77 life expect considering yeah the
health problems that he had he had a
[__] triple by
pass so that bypass bought him bought
him another six years in a way that's
kind of crazy to think about I was
trying to think how old like my cuz my
dad is my dad is still alive but um I
was starting to think how old my
grandfather was because he also had
diabetes and he smoked like his whole
entire life and didn't quit and he also
had lung cancer yeah um you know he was
on oxygen I'm trying to think how old he
was he was born in 1919 and he died in
199 91 okay I think so somebody math
that 70 something years yeah and my
grandma was 79 when she died she smoked
a long time too but she quit like
probably about 10 or 20 years before she
died just cold turkey she just got up
one day and decided to quit and she did
and she never smoked again which is
crazy to me but she did no 77 from my
dad he was lucky to live that long yeah
you know yeah murder Hornet says Tom
Tom's girl messengered him I don't know
what he's talking about Tom GF
messengered him okay I don't know what
that he's
pyro Tom's girlfriend messed him I don't
know what he's talking about I don't
know either yeah what what are you
talking
about who's who's the him it's like who
who are you talking
about uh yeah Camp guy said I just took
my 15-year-old toy poodle to the vet
over 500 bucks for shots medicine blood
work etc Jesus Christ
I'm just I'm kind of hoping our KES stay
healthy they're still young I mean Pooky
will
be
seven this summer is she seven yeah
should be seven this summer uh bam if
they were right about her age will be
two next month okay roughly all right
because when we got her she was 18
months old yeah and we've had her for
almost six months at this point wa these
cats live they can live a long time they
could live 15 20 years they better some
cats can live a 20 years I think I think
most of them are about 12 15 I
think but depends depends on yeah it
depend well I've known people cars and
[__] well and I mean well ours don't go
outside so but um I've known some people
that had cats that live like 20 years or
more than 20 years so it's possible but
it's some it depends on the cap and
stuff like that yeah murder Hunter just
say
at at what is at at at he's
drunk I guess so yeah he's drunk this is
this is a mystery now that we're trying
to solve
yeah he's tried to call me like this
before oh yeah yeah not make any [__]
sense well he yeah he calls my phone
yeah cuz thinking it's me yeah yeah well
because Tom doesn't really he he has a
tablet yeah he has a tablet yeah so he
doesn't have a cell phone so whenever he
has need for phones he's got to use my
phone yeah
and somehow that [__] murder horned up
thinking that I had a phone in that he
could call me he gets drunk and starts
want to talk and [__] cuz I didn't
answer a [__] text or some [__] like
that he's like a chick man [__] you
know where the [__] are you I texted you
[__] we're not
dating Fu crazy [__] that's
really funny he's another he's another
VA dude nothing [__] crazy VA dude
that's crazy like from the Predator
movie
with all the crazy crazy VA dudes that's
us yeah sitting around getting that free
money going to Mexico beating up bums
and [__] well he doesn't beat up with
bums he just [__] videos tapes them
he's got his favorite bums he talks to
and he [__] records my favorite bums
yeah he's got his favorite bums yeah
funny what is he gonna pay him to make
know Nam is he gonna pay him to make him
fight he's on F now he's on first name
basis with him wasn't that some [__]
that went on in in the '90s OR early
2000s wasn't there like a bum fights.com
or something where people were where
Shady people were going around paying
bums to fight each other and then they
were taping it and putting it up on now
he pays bombs to [__] uh get stuff
for him and to take him to the
brothel how how is the bum gonna take
you anywh I don't know [__] bum will
take him around all the brothel and [__]
and he gives some money I mean they
don't have a car they're a bum no they
walk he can't walk he can't walk by
himself he didn't know where they were
oh okay bumma take him there like a
guide oh all right yeah like a sherpa
he's on Safari a bum Sherpa yeah I got
you he was [__] he goes into this
Mexican broel with his phone
streaming showing the girls and had me
pick one out for him which one did you
pick he's said which one which one I
pick the best one he goes yeah she was
cute you picked the best one yeah well
which one she was nice I know just some
chick laying in a [__] g string
laying on a [__]
laying on a couch laying on a couch she
okay okay she gets so so he agreed with
your with your assessment it all went
well yeah said that one right there that
right there and she goes
look she's reading a book got
up this is the kind of [__] they're
doing what's that this is the kind of
[__] they're doing yeah yeah it's
[__] South of the Border
action yeah Zach is talking about uh the
friend that he wants to help out cool
okay and and uh said I do have a crush
on this friend too aha so the truth
comes out yeah okay and I'm a man I know
and y'all only ever do stuff cuz you
wants to get something get his dick wet
he's trying to get something out of it
he's gonna Zach on a power bottom on him
[__] just coming on him coming
down like that you're pretty good at
that Tom I [__] twerk for a
living going to that's going to be on my
[__]
family one of these days when you put
something I don't have anything yet you
still haven't put anything how long how
many months have you had that [__]
long time and you haven't put and I keep
saying it's like when are you going to
put something on there okay I say on I
say I say the thing said don't buy
anything because I'm I haven't put
anything up
yet been too
busy he just never gets around to it cuz
I keep telling him it's like hey I want
most gag I want some I want some videos
too come on send it to me J just wants
videos I want videos well you can put
them up there if you want to but I want
them too all right one of these days
he's never going to do it um no I might
I might he might do it I just got to get
in a mood yeah I know uh and then Zach
says I'm mad at myself cuz I'm almost 30
and keep getting these like first High
School type crushes on guys I don't know
why it's so annoying you're emotional
and [__] well I mean and honestly like
if you're not even 30 yet that's still
pretty young I know it seems like you
seem like an old you know you you you
feel like an old person but you're
you're really not like take it for me a
person in my
50s uh Tammy said Pooky just has her
winter weight that's what I say about
our two cats yeah she's lost a little
bit of weight since we got Bambi because
they chase each other around and so
she's running around a lot more but she
is a little Chub but that's okay we're
but we are thinking about maybe not
putting as many treats out as we usually
do but see if you don't if you don't put
a sufficient amount out they Riot yeah
like Pooky will climb into the thing and
she starts knocking everything just
pushing
everything and then she goes there and
looks at the tra looks at the at at the
[__] empty plate yeah she she knocks
him out and look at the empty plate and
then look at you and then look at the
plate she knows how had to communicate
yeah she's like what is this [__]
here yeah there's not enough and she
just sits there by then you put treats
there and she goes thank you and she
walks away she doesn't eat them right
then wasn't even hungry just it planning
for the future yeah don't for one second
believe it when people say well animals
can't don't have any foresight they
can't oh no they they can plan for the
future they she absolutely does they
know when we leave the house she's like
hey hey hey hey hey food food put food
down she like flips out and like runs by
the thing she's like don't leave me with
no food yeah yeah she knows you guys are
leaving yeah she want a whole supply of
them she's like all right the more this
St the more calm she is okay that'll
last me yeah she's like I don't know how
long you [__] are going to be gone
you might be gone a long time right
right right so it's like so no they're
they're they're I better have Provisions
they're very human
like it's [__] funny man they're like
humans it's just not the same
proportions mentally yeah she's just
she's like a little kid I mean she's
like a little human kid Bambi's kind of
like a little human kid too kind of in a
different way their personalities are a
lot different but you
know their senses are different yeah
their their vision is different and
everything so it affects their world
yeah but you can still understand
understand what they're thinking about
yeah I mean I can still understand what
they're trying to communicate to me it's
not really that you know Danny says I
just got the last man on Earth in color
on DVD o nice yeah the one with Vincent
Price like um the one that's based on I
Am Legend yeah yeah they colorized it
there is a colorized version yeah okay
uh good yeah completing the collection
including the Omega Man and I am Legend
I don't know if I've ever watched the
colorized version I love that movie
that's probably my favorite version
actually I think that's the most
accurate version to the book yeah um you
know I love the Omega Man too but it's
not they changed it a lot each one of
those is its own story it really is it's
and I am Legend Will Smith's I Am Legend
is better than I remembered it when I
watched it again it's still not great
though they made a mistake of not
allowing the mutants to speak they were
just Mindless
monsters which just kind of makes it
like every other zombie movie
yeah and that's just dumb cuz even the
original the zombies or not the zombies
the mutants spoke yeah mutants there in
the book they're kind of vampires Vamp
they're vampires they spoke and they saw
themselves as normal and they saw him
Neville the last human being as a
monster because he was running around
killing them while they were sleeping
yeah so he was a monster they kind of
did that in the Omega Man where the what
the
family they saw Neville as a monster and
and some and evil from the past yeah um
which that's closer to the book yeah but
they weren't vampires though yeah in the
book they were yeah in the book they
were vampires in in Omega Man they
were they were mutants that had survived
a biological
warfare and they turned into albinos who
were real sensitive to sunlight they
were they were blind in the Sun so they
only came out at night and it turned
them into Psychopaths and they had uh
sores but they weren't vampires yeah
they weren't drinking
blood I'm pretty sure in the I I kind of
want to reread the book because I
haven't read it for a few years I don't
know if they use the word vampires in
the book but I mean the way that they're
described that's pretty much what they
are
yeah last man on Earth they're vampires
yeah so like I'm saying the Vincent
Price one they changed some [__] too but
last man on Earth is the most accurate
to the novel it's still not exactly the
same but but and the novel's really good
like you know so I I love Richard mat
all his [__] is good it's good he's
written so much [__] that like horror
was he wrote dual he wrote like a
bajillion Twilight Zone episodes Night
Gallery episodes um and he just wrote
some great [__] books man I like hell
house I I I liked them all but I prefer
Omega man there's something about
Charlton hon and uh downtown Los Angeles
totally devoid of people which they were
able to film somehow filming at the
right time J and it it they make La seem
totally desolate which is crazy that
they were able to do that he's driving
around in his [__]
Mustang with his [__] Smith and
Weston mk760 submachine gun and going to
see [__] Woodstock at the movies and
stealing gasoline and if he wrecks a car
he just gets another
car and uh he thinks he's the last man
on Earth and his his house has been
converted into this big
fortress [__] guns and search lights
and he has a huge collection of guns and
survival stuff and statues of [__]
Julius Caesar and it's like a museum in
there and he's got cameras
and he's just he's taken his own
personal house and just turned it into a
fortress and he goes out at night
hunting those hunting
those mutants and kills
them he tried to heal them but it didn't
work uh so he just tried to kill them
because they were running around burning
all the libraries and destroying the
past cuz they were bad too you know the
the family and the mutants they weren't
good they were they were
psychos it's just a great movie and it
just has a weird
alienating feel to it I saw when I was a
kid it made an impression on me and I
have it on DVD I don't have a Blu-ray
but I have a DVD version of it and it's
just fcking it's weird to watch and uh
it's a Melancholy movie there's
something about
it and
uh there's just something about Charlton
Hon's portrayal of of
Neville as kind of
like man who is a rational scientist but
he's also a [__] killer ape you know
what I mean he's primitive and he's
Advanced at the same time so there's a
lot of duality in him which I liked it
uh
um run around his old uniform because he
was an Air Force Major or colel I think
in a bioweapons program he's he was the
only guy he thought s he was the only
guy that survived untouched because he
was working on the antidote yeah for the
thing for the disease and uh he was
going to deliver it somewhere and the
helicopter Tri crashed and out of
desperation he gave himself an ejection
of it all the rest all the rest was lost
too late now well he lived because had
injections he was immune to it he was
the only person
immune later on he finds out that his
blood could be used as a serum and as an
antidote to other people but it didn't
work on people who were already affected
as bad as the mutants he he said he
captured one of them and gave him some
of his blood and a serum and he died
badly that's all he said he died bad but
he didn't tell us exactly what happened
I think actually they did kind of show
what he did to him they were fighting in
the remember he kind of flash he's
fighting him in the [__] laboratory
and kills him I think with a machine
gun grur says I recently Googled an
exgirlfriend from 20 years ago and found
out that she died in 2013 is that what
that says death trate she died from
liver sepsis from years of is that eth
abuse kind of a shock to find this out
what's eth yeah I don't know
it's big all big letters all capital
letters so I'm not really sure what that
is that's pretty
freaky you can buy Action
Figures it's like a 12in army or like a
GI Joe
doll and there's a whole Black Market of
people [__] getting faces and you
know and and and making them with with
that uh what do you call
it 3D printing and they you can 3D print
now the actual face of a of a star and
somebody
made out of scratch an action figure of
Neville and his and his military uniform
and everything and the face was charlon
hon I saw the charlon hon head somebody
was selling it uh one of them but he
wanted like 50 bucks for the
head but you can I almost thought about
doing that that'd be cool to put
together a Neville yeah action
figure
okay I'm way behind our comment okay um
yeah Camp guy said I told this on a
previous episode but I have a cat that
is so old that her front claws have
rounded back and grown into her uh pads
well [__] did you cut them grossest
thing I've ever seen but you got to cut
them though well yeah you do got to cut
them yeah yeah they're almost perfect
almost perfect circle growing back into
her
feet yeah hopefully my daughter is
taking to the veterinarian because we
gave that cat to her okay so they get
yeah that cat is maybe even 20 years old
yeah and um yeah somebody B like Iris
said Pooky is still pretty young yeah
like I said she's not even seven uh at
the rate you're taking care of her good
chance she'll live uh close to 20 I hope
so I mean you
know cuz you know both of them they're
my babies you know what I mean I I don't
want anything bad to happen to them uh
Dave is here all right hey boys and
girls he says mannequins tonight Marty
goth Knight yeah yeah we'll be there
yeah we're going we're going tonight be
there I forgot that the theme was
go I wonder if anybody's going to like
dress up I don't know they probably they
usually have a costume contest but we
haven't been in a while so I don't
really know how it's going to go and
Zach says uh uh oh no I say 30 as in
should be more mature about romantic
[__] at this point I don't know like I
said I didn't really figure [__] out
until I was probably like in my late 30s
so don't feel too
bad you know um Zan says Jenny I watched
your history of horror movies yesterday
and loved it really great job on that
video thank you so much I apologize for
taking so long because I think I
announced that I was working on it way
back before Halloween cuz my you know my
intention was to put it up for Halloween
cuz it was going to be like this big
special event and then I was just like
when I started working on I'm like oh my
God this is like so much work and then
it just took me so long like to get
around to doing it because I just didn't
have time so I'm glad I just finally got
it up and I was just like [__] it I'll
just put it up whenever I get it up but
it did come out good I'm I'm actually
pretty proud of it I'm actually pretty
proud of it um yeah Z said I listened to
it while I was at work yeah so it's up
there if anybody wants to watch it it's
just in the in the regular I think I put
it in the episodes
playlist I really need to do some put
something up on my scar Salon Channel
too because I don't think I've put
anything up on there for a while need to
get back into the Boris carof thriller
or the Night Gallery show because I
still bought I bought all those night
Galler night galleries we haven't seen
them all yet yeah and I have I mean I've
seen them all lots of times but I
haven't reviewed them you know what I
mean um let's see what like Danny says I
can't uh I can't watch I Am Legend
anymore because Will Smith is a jag
off I mean I don't I never really liked
that movie like I said I didn't really
like that they just turned it into legit
like straight up a zombie movie I'm just
like yeah we've got lots of it could
have been so much better had they talked
and it been more like uh I am U Omega
Man or last man on Earth they could have
done it but they didn't they they dumbed
it down I think will would have been
good at
that and U the setting and the CG was
okay the CG of the monsters wasn't very
good they should have just been
people yeah I mean yeah it would have
been better well like I said and that's
what the book was like so I I don't know
why they had to change it so much they
just like I said they just turned it
into like an action zombie movie which
like I said we've got lots of those why
did we need another one
dumb uh yeah Zan said the CGI ruined I
Am Legend yeah Will Smith acting uh by
himself I enjoyed well there was CGI of
the city that looked pretty good it was
the CGI of the the monsters I didn't
love and then Zach said hey did you guys
say that you never reviewed Dolores
Clayborn yeah we haven't and I actually
really love that movie and it's a great
book too but we I don't think we've ever
got around to reviewing s asked me about
uh he asked me about U Neville too from
Omega Man you passed it where is it well
like I said I got got way behind I got
way
behind
uh where is it I can't see see if I can
find it yeah you find it because I can't
find
it
uh yeah Zena said didn't he have a black
girlfriend in Omega Man and it was a big
deal at the time yeah yeah I kind of
feel like well okay so Omega Man came
out in what 70
early 7s 71 I think it was 71 yeah and
when was well I know the first
interracial kiss on TV was Captain Kirk
and Aura right yeah that was 60s though
and that was 60s yeah but I'm just
saying that even at this point in the
early 1970s that was still kind of a
yeah well at the time you know the the
the the director and and the people that
were on like the directing team that did
it said at the time black nationalism
was [__] uh really big and they
thought that if they were to have like a
black panther in there as a character
and that and that she's and it's a
female she's getting it on with Neville
would be real [__] spicy for the time
live I get it work yeah and if you
haven't seen the movie what what they're
talking about is that Neville ends up
finding that not
everyone not everyone is turned into a
in into a mutant there are some people
that have
it but they kind of have a resistance to
to it but they could flip at any
moment so they look
normal but they could turn at any time
he finds out that he could heal them
with his
blood well one of them is uh black chick
probably late 20s early 30s with um I
don't remember the the actress's name I
don't even remember the character's name
but she's real good in the movie she's
kind of like
uh he's the first person she sees he's
he's Scavenging through department
stores looking for a new jogging suit
cuz he jogs every
morning and um she sees him and freezes
like she's a mannequin and she does
blend in with the mannequins but
eventually he's like hey you know and
then she ran runs off that mannequin's
breathing and he chases her but she
loses him in the
park and he thought he hallucinated it
he thought he had gone crazy because he
was losing his mind he kept
he
kept at any moment he could [__]
start hearing every telephone in the
city ringing at once it would drive him
crazy yeah he was goes the phone is not
ringing there is no phone it's that that
scared the [__] out of me when I was a
kid that scene and um